Wendy Williams breaks her silence
following new cheating allegations
against her husband we've got a lot to
talk about
it's we're doing hot topics and being a
hot topic in a weird kind of way Norman
I love the attention
Wendy came to her man's defense after a
report claimed he is living a double
life and having an affair with a massage
therapist for over a decade the talk
show host responded to infidelity rumors
during her Hot Topic segment on Tuesday
it's some sort of weird story going
around the internet regarding my husband
now look I'm a straight shooter pop out
all you got to do is google him and you
see the story you can believe what you
want but I stand by my guy we commuted
this morning the paparazzi was outside
catching me in the cutest negligee oh
well you know so then you know I like
clothes that all you have to do is pluck
them off yes I know you do and to get to
the business yep the 53 year old star
will celebrate 20 years of marriage with
her husband in November anyway
[Music]
don't believe the hype and if there was
high believe me you I would let you know
[Applause]
by the way I'll be following this story
so I guess I'll have to watch to find
out what happens
[Applause]
you